كيف بني الهرم الاكبر اين غرفه الدفن
الخاصه بالملك خوفو واين اثاره اسرار لم
تكشف بعد عن هرم خوفو احد عجائب الدنيا
السبع ولكن يبدو اننا على مشارف كشف
المزيد عن واحد من اقدم الابنيه في
التاريخ سكان بيراميدز مشروع دولي ضخم
لاستكشاف هرم خوفو باستخدام احدث الوسائط
التكنولوجيه اسفر عن اول كشف داخل الهرم
ممر جملوني او سرداب خلف المدخل الشمالي
للهرم بطوله تسعه امتار وعرض حوالي مترين
يرجح انه لتخفيف الاحمال عن شيء ما خلفه
ربما تكون غرفه دفن الملك خوفو التي لم
يعثر عليها حتى اليوم بحسب عالم الاثار
زاهي حواس النهارده
من شكله الجملوني وطوله والفتحه اللي انا
شفتها في الناحيه الشماليه اللي بتبين فيه
فراغ موجود ده انا
اسفل هذا الكوليدور بتوجد حجره الدفن
الاصليه الخاصه بهرم المال خوفو ودي هتكون
عمليه البحث التانيه اللي هنقوم بها
اعتبارا من غدا ماذا عن هذا الممر تخفيف
احمال عن ايه هل يجوز يكون المدخل اللي
احنا بندخل منه حاليا عشان المسافه احنا
بنتكلم على سبعه متر طب واشمعنا بتربط
الربط ده عند غرفه الملك خوفو فوقيها خمس
غرف لتخفيف الضغط واخر غرفه سقفها جملوني
لو بصينا السقف الجمالي اللي فوق مع غرفه
الدفن بنلاقي برضه المسافه سبعه متر فهل
هو ده تخفيف الضغط بس ام يخفي اثار واسرار
لم نعرفها بعد الفريق العلمي للمشروع يعمل
في هذا الكشف منذ 2015 باستخدام وسائط
حديثه غير ضاره بالهرم لاكتشاف ما بداخله
مثل الموجات فوق الصوتيه والاشعه تحت
الحمراء وايضا استخدام روبوت لادخال
كاميرا في ثقب صغير في الهرم انا ابتدينا
به
ان في حاجه هنا احنا بنسميها علميا انه
مالي يعني معناه في حاجه غير طبيعيه هنا
حطينا افلام الميو واحد عشان عشان نشوف هل
احنا شايفين بدايه ظواهر لقينا من فعل ان
في فراغ موجود بس حاجه كده
محتاجه ان احنا نعدلها اكثر هذا المشروع
العلمي والتاريخي له اهميه كبيره فبعثت
الاثر ما زالت تبحث عن كنوز الملك خوفو من
الدوله القديمه صاحب البناء الاشهر في
التاريخ كشف يعتبره العلماء اهم
الاكتشافات عن الهرم الاكبر في القرن
الحالي استخدام التكنولوجيا الحديثه الغير
مدمره ساعدت في الكشف عن اسرار وخبايا هرم
خوفو وطريقه البناء سمر باشات العربيه
اهرامات الجيزه